[Music]
so your uncle that you mentioned I've
heard you talk about how he influenced
your sort of awakening to this stuff so
people might find that interesting that
there there was a gay man you know let's
say 15 years ago or so in the South that
existed yeah how was life for him I know
that sounds sort of ridiculous now I
think people actually don't understand
that ear right but even before gay
marriage gay people existed lived live
some good some bad you know just like
everybody else well so when I was a kid
my uncle lived in Nashville and I think
another thing a lot of people don't
realize is that for the most part in a
lot of ways cities are cities whether in
ham Alabama is still a city which means
there's still plenty of like liberal
ideals and whatever else there and so
like he lived in Nashville which is
totally different totally different than
Salina but he came back a lot and then
when I was in high school from then on
he did live in Salina and now I thought
before after I've now that I'm an adult
that maybe there's a good possibility
that he did go through a lot of shitty
things shitty treatment whatever else
but like he didn't tell me about it
because I was a kid and he threatened
you I mean and I had enough bad [ __ ]
going on he didn't want to like burden
me with it or whatever and that's a very
good possibility but so far as I'm aware
he never faced anything like he
definitely never gotten you like beat up
he never got like you know he had a
deadly they're in town for a while
whatever else and he never got like a
brick thrown through the window or
nothing like that
and then um he's not the only gay guy in
the town either in fact there was a guy
and I don't know there's a local
businessman who is a gay guy and when
when I was in high school he used to he
had a lot of money especially for that
area and so when we were in high school
he'd come to high school ball games in
Salina Tennessee with like two little
like Cuban boy toys especially oh there
are a lot of condoms boy toy Oh
Tennessee I don't know where he got okay
that's was Ryan nobody did
but what I mean is like I mean he was
launching it yeah and nothing ever
happened to him either
right everybody
Chicago it's Steve you know how Steve is
you know what I'm thinking never like
what happened to Cubans out of that well
you know baby was done with them they
went back or whatever he got me and then
he got to Ukrainian boy toys or whatever
I don't know but right yeah and that's
I didn't again at the time I didn't
realize how insane that would probably
be to a lot of people to know that that
had happened there and running that they
didn't get you know tarred and feathered
or whatever just that it was just a
thing that people I mean you know that
people were definitely like oh here he
goes again you know what I mean
but even that was like the extent of it
and it's still not okay to be disgusted
by gay people obviously but like it
never translated to any kind of like
violence or like out you know get the
hell out of our town types I never saw
anything like that no mostly just don't
talk about it yeah you know what I mean
in a weird way though that actually is
okay right because it's like you
actually are allowed to be disgusted by
somebody or be racist °o° or being run
in order like you can be like yeah we
don't like it you know you shouldn't
dislike on to the color of their skin er
yeah that's actually but at the end of
the day you're saying it's a lot of Lube
and let live people there so even if
they saw it they didn't like it as long
as you're not hurting somebody then what
are you going to do I gotta remember
once when I was a kid
it's son like if I practice or something
some older kid was giving me [ __ ]
because my uncle was gay or whatever
which wasn't a rare thing and after his
over some this guy who I still like he's
one of the most outwardly
stereotypically redneck people you
couldn't imagine I mean he is like a
openly red Swamp People type guy right
like I mean as red as it gets especially
in this place I'm like he came up to me
afterwards you know and was like he's
like a your uncle's a good man tre you
know don't let him do whatever like that
kind of thing and that's I'm saying
there was a lot of that to like I don't
know it's way way more complicated than
people realize like it's not just this
but but then I meet people I meet people
on the road I've got a lot of gay fans
and so like I meet gay people in like
Portland or wherever who grew up in
Alabama you know what I mean and there
and they just have just horror stories
you know what I mean so like and I know
they're not lying I know that's the
reality so again it's complicated
you know so you're telling me your
personal experience can't blanket the
entire thing I can't believe it
Yeah right that's crazy I my anecdotal
experience it's not as bad as people
think it is but there's still a lot of
room for improvement yeah where does the
religion piece get mixed in that because
I think a lot of the sort of the coasts
you know the New York LA sort of hatred
or mocking of rednecks and southern
culture is because of the religious
attachment particularly Christianity
because it's the easiest thing to attack
all the time how much of that stuff is
associated with religion do you think a
couple years ago I would have told you
just about every single bit of it I used
to when people ask me how I became a
liberal redneck or whatever I would talk
about my uncle like I already did but
the effect that that had was I stopped
going to church because of all the
homophobic [ __ ] they were spouting or
whatever
and I was like what the hell with that
you know like why would I take Jesus
aside over my uncle you know I mean I
ain't never even emailed you you know
I'm not going to take his so right I
left the church and that's and so that's
what I always thought that's what I
always attributed a lot of that to and I
blamed the church for a lot of these
attitudes in the pack really been
enlightened a lot myself in the past
couple years with that especially the
past year being on tour and talking to
so many people in so many places and my
to tour mates and co-authors Cory and
drew they grew up heavily in the church
and ultimately left it you know which
checks out right after talking to them
and talking to so many other people at
shows and stuff I don't think it's it's
that simple
I think that that has a lot to do with
it a whole lot to do with it
but I used to blame I used to be like if
there was no if we weren't the Bible
Belt if you took all the Jesus out of
the south it'd be totally fine that's
not true it's just not because of the
economic factors and you still have the
whole historical factors and racial
factors and all that kind of stuff that
wouldn't go away just because you got
rid of Jesus but so I mean it it
definitely has a lot to do with it
though for sure particularly when it
comes to
gay right gay people and Muslims and the
way they feel about those two groups I
still think is mostly Jesus's fault
because I think that Jesus right even
though Jesus probably would have been
with a Muslim that well that's even
around a lot of Muslims it was middle
east and yeah well I'm not talking about
the actual Jesus I'm talking about you
know Jesus the first American who rode
to Texas on a trying to carry rocks with
a machine gun design yeah that Jesus
yeah speaking of Jesus so tell me about
your come to Jesus moment when you said
okay I am a liberal like when so you had
your uncle you had this sort of
awakening but when were you like this is
the political stuff that I believe in
did you have to actually sort of come
out to people that you knew I well again
I mentioned briefly earlier that like I
never I never realized it was weird
until probably like I think probably in
late high school or college was when I
realized like how different it was like
I never thought much about the fact that
I disagreed with certain people about
certain things but the biggest factor
was again like I said people just didn't
really talk about that stuff so it never
really got you know tossed around for me
to realize oh man we're on completely
different pages right the first time
that I can remember really thinking that
outside of just the you know gay rights
thing which I just chalked up is a
religious thing not a political thing
was in high school in our English class
we would have like debates because we
didn't have a debate team or debate
class or nothing we'd had debates like
once every other week and one time in
debate class things teacher was like
okay so it's like mm 2 or 3 everybody
everybody thinks we should not go to war
everybody thinks we should go to war
with Iraq raise your hand and it's not
half the students or whatever and she
was like okay everybody thinks that we
shouldn't go over that right raise your
hand and it was literally just me like I
was going again I threw my hand up
without even thinking about yeah of
course but I looked around and I got the
only one and then that other half of the
crowd were you know she said okay now if
you just don't know or don't care raise
your hand and that was
the other half of the class she was like
okay everybody doesn't care you're with
Trey everybody whatever but that's a
pretty enlightened teacher giving you to
all the people that didn't really care
grind it to the piece get this guy
instead but work out well you know but
ended up just being me against all of
them which I was fine with yeah but but
that was probably the first time that I
sort of had that as you said come to
Jesus moment where I realized that like
I wasn't like most of the people that I
was surrounded by yeah when did you get
into the Senate so I wanted to be a
stand-up since I was 12
Chris Rock bigger and blacker came out I
watched it with my dad yep and that's
what I was like you know I want to do
that but it was never a question of me
like going to college or not like with
my dad my grandpa boy it's like you know
I was going to go to college I was me
the first wanted for my family to
graduate from college whenever else like
it was a big thing and so I did and I'm
glad I did I don't regret it at all but
I focused on that for a while and by the
time I got I went to business school and
by the time ago I was 24 and that's when
I was like okay if I'm ever going to do
comedy at all it needs to be now and so
that's when I started when I was 24 6
1/2 years ago thank God your success
because if you were the first family
member to go to college and business
school and then you became a failed
Hokkien man that would that would be the
the worst day possible
it's funny my dad my dad was always cool
with it
my dad because my dad was mostly cool
with everything you know what I mean but
my dad died when I tell him I want to be
a comedian or being show business
whatever he does sounds cuccos
you know but outside of him though every
other like authority figure in my life
from my grandfather's to guidance
counselor's teachers whatever because
always made really good grades and they
would tell me like you know you can you
have an opportunity to get out of here
and you can do whatever you want you can
be a lawyer you can be a doctor you know
all this stuff and I would and out if I
told them I think I wanna be your
comedian they've got no work no not that
don't do that right you know like you're
gonna wait on this credential you have
yeah
whatever like you got to do this that
was the universal response to that was
like why he's going to he's going to
waste it all trying to be a comedian or
whatever is what I got a lot of BS
working out yeah it is working so now
you're in LA I really treat you as our
LA for a redneck well it's fine for me I
don't mind it you know I'm doing fine
with it but uh I do I think it's weird
for people around me a lot right I
definitely get a lot of like you know
sideways glances and stuff like that at
times like I got I've got two little
boys somehow I might boys at the park or
something and I'm yelling at them
because they're doing something they
shouldn't be doing yeah you know I mean
but I'm yelling at a child and this like
I got damn it I don't you know what I
mean like a truck or head-on whoever
else and mine I noticed that like oh
they stopped doing couples yoga over
there on the main like this is
off-putting to people yeah and just
hearing the Southern drawl and we just
don't hear here forgetting not really
you like it or not again you just simply
don't hear it yeah and I mean so yes I
get a lot of like you know that kind of
thing but I mean I think it's funny you
know it's fun I don't mind it yeah so
when I was watching a bunch of your
youtube videos in the last couple days I
thought wow here is a liberal that I
agree with on so much and it's funny I
told you before you know I'm I was born
in Brooklyn I lived my whole life in New
York City until I moved out to LA so the
only two places I ever lived are New
York in LA and then I watch yourself and
I find this this Tennessee redneck who's
a liberal who I'm going this guy gets
what liberalism is what do you sense
about the general state of liberalism
because it's become like a hot button
word that can be used I guess a little
bit in a positive way but almost at all
levels now it's being used as a negative
way well yeah I've been my allies yeah
my liberal allies I think it's starting
to I think every little night I think
it's to me in a lot of ways liberalism
has jumped the shark
oh my kids just like just went too far
with so many things and mean you were
talking off air earlier about the fact
that like
where I'm from right and we've already
kind of touched on it where I'm from and
where I've spent most of my life I'm
Mike I'm Karl Marx man I like I am as
far left as it gets
yeah they're out here in California I'm
you know a centrist or whatever probably
because that's just how much further and
it's true on both sides though is the
thing if I could the Tea Party whatever
else and how it politically was been
pushed to the polls you know the
opposite extremes and it's absolutely
true on the left too and I don't really
know what has happened to cause that I
think it's just like maybe the cultural
divide between the two and just like you
know going back and forth and sort of
pushing each other the distaste that
each side has for the other side just
pushes them as far a you know as much
further away from the opposition as they
can go there are something there again
I'm just comedian I'm pulling out on my
ass no but like that's you know what not
something like that I guess yeah well
look all of our own personal experiences
are what make the reality of it right so
I mean that's exactly I've been talking
about for a long time I've watched the
left go off this way I've watched the
right go off this way I'm a firm
believer that there's huge spot right
now for people somewhere in the middle
it's funny because I have a lot of
libertarians on and I now find much more
in common as a liberal with libertarians
that I do with leftist right there so
what do we do with that as good liberals
that want to bring the left well I can
ever my thing is like economically but
not across the board but in most ways
economically like libertarianism is not
for me there's a lot of [ __ ] that they
subscribe to that I don't at all yeah so
you want you want more of them being
from Bama don't what so you want more of
a state you see more utility for a state
in taxes yes I got yeah I think I'd
really think that it's necessary now
don't get me wrong a lot of bloat like
and it's it's at way out of hand and
does need to be reined in some I know
that's also a little personal to me
because I said I went to business school
so I wasn't waiting tables doing comp
moonlighting as a comedian I worked for
the US Department
of energy that was my day job when I was
like getting into comedy and so I mean I
know firsthand about like the bloat of
the federal government and me and the
inefficiencies of our bureaucracy and
all that and it needs to be cleaned up
but I think it's necessary though that
you have a government that sort of
regulates and police's some of these
other systems particular basically man I
just don't trust rich people to do
what's right for everybody else yeah I
never have and I don't think I ever will
because that's just human nature I think
they're going to do a trap for them and
the people like in their own
self-interest not across the board but
by and large and so I think we need
systems in place to sort of keep that
from happening if possible yeah isn't
that the catch-22 also though because
now the government is run by rich people
too and yeah a panel is ameno well so
it's like we either have business rich
people doing it or political rich people
and we're all kind of caught well that
little that's the thing is I'm a big
believer in that you know that we live
in a plutocracy and that's a big problem
for me because of everything I just said
but that is the reality of it I do think
yes the rich people run the government
or whatever and that you know that's a
damn shame
but like I'm saying philosophically yeah
I I do think there's a definite need for
government I think you have to have it
but uh but socially though and in a lot
of other ways libertarians
I'm absolutely more in line with them on
like I mean I'm pro-legalization of
really just about any drug to be honest
with me and I'm also pro-gun growing up
that that's the that's the least liberal
thing about me but it says to me it's a
freedom thing it actually is a liberal
thing but it's not a leftist right after
the difference right liberal so you can
protect yourself that is a liberal right
oh yeah I've actually I've never bought
a gun I own seventeen guns because I
inherited my grandfather's Arsenal cry
you know and so but I'm saying in the
South run from that it's super common
everybody and so like it's not weird to
me
it's not like Daniel why would you want
to own a gun I was like why wouldn't you
want like I all for background checks
and all that kind of stuff the gun show
loopholes and all that need to be closed
I'm all for all that but just generally
speaking I got no problem with guns and
I you know Pro I'm very I'm a believer
in freedom real freedom you know what I
mean enough that's the way I've always
looked at gay rights too you know what I
mean like he's painting the privacy of
your own home bedroom whatever else go
wild long as you're not hurting anybody
who gives a [ __ ] yeah makes my cardboard
for me yeah you're a classical liberal
but I guess for a tour claiming the
classical liberal you just drop the
classic right Yeah right well and also
well that and I mean I'm aware of the
distinction again philosophically yeah
but my whole life like in the south or
in the rural South especially like a
liberal liberal man you know whatever
hey like I hear you're either a liberal
or you're not yeah he'll always like
classical versus progressive liberal
whatever they don't know that [ __ ]
matters where I'm from you're gonna mean
so like I never thought about it in
those terms right but but yes so I mean
yeah you're right that's funny I gotta
clean I'm yeah yeah I got to get my show
to Tennessee then because that's what
I've been trying to do is show people
the difference between real liberalism
and and what has happened here oh they
definitely need that stuff because
that's the I mean right they well that's
the whole that's a big thing in the
south for a long time as people ask why
they vote against their self-interest
you know no matter whatever else it's
like because they don't think that you
reflect their self-interest you know
what I mean and I think arguably a lot
of liberal policies do but all they know
about liberals is this like you know
elitist frou-frou overi overly PC like
they're you know that whole thing is all
that they're aware of when it comes to
liberals and and it's like a total
non-starter for most of them
[Music]
you
[Music]